so that we want to talk to some of the
people who knew him best here at Fox
starting with his friend of many years
britt hume who joins us tonight but
people loved charles krauthammer even
people who disagreed with them what was
it about him that they were responding
to well it was a rare combination Tucker
in the sense that he had this
extraordinary intellect one that all of
us sort of admired and none of us
realized I'm none of us thought we could
ever come close to equaling he was
literally in a class by himself he was
he was one of a kind and on top of that
he had for all the sharpness of his
thought in writing and sometimes his
language on television he was
extraordinarily kind and gentle and the
combination made you love him and we did
all of us did the audience did you
couldn't help it and you know you think
of what we're doing here tonight Tucker
we're all feeling sad and sorry but look
we're on we've been on the air now since
6 o'clock when this news broke and we
and we're talking about this one subject
and you know you might say well that's
because you know you know he was on Fox
and he was our guy yeah that's true
but he was a giant of our time and of
our trade and he carried it out in the
in the in the height of the highest
standards he wrote beautifully he was
careful about his facts he thought
things through and he conducted himself
with extraordinary dignity and grace and
we could all see it and could only
aspire to it no bitterness pure humanity
his instincts were so relentlessly
decent I don't think I knew anyone who
disliked him now I know people who you
know disagreed with him and they were
sometimes annoyed or offended by you
know the sharpness with which he rode
people who for example were not as
sympathetic yet Israel as Charles
unfailingly was right but on a personal
level and if you ever saw him or watched
him you couldn't you couldn't dislike
him it was you couldn't help but admire
him because even if you disagreed with
him you recognized the power of his
thought the thoroughness of his
search and the quality of his writing
and the combination was was stronger
than of course we knew him personally
there was that wonderful quality that he
had that kindness that gentleness that
grace and of course if you knew what
he'd been through and you could see what
he had overcome and you saw the way he
handled all that it made him you know
you admired him as it was as you'd
probably didn't admire anybody else I
can't think of anyone on earth that I
admired more than I admired Charles
Krauthammer and I admire him to this day
you speak for so many when you say that
Brit Hume thank you another truly great
insincere man thanks